yeah you were mentioning the 90s it
matically got automatic got me thinking
about when I saw a country music in the
90s I saw women in front women in charge
and things kind of took a little dip
change a bit and now we're seeing more
women again coming out and being being
supported the way I feel like they
should be supported do you feel like
this trend is more than just a trend
like something that is gonna stay I've
seen it go everywhere I've seen it go
very traditional country back up to
contemporary I've seen the women be on
top and then the men are just kind of
waiting for their turn and here comes
now here comes the men so yeah it'll be
cyclical it'll come back yeah looking at
your Instagram I have to say I'm all the
jealous of all the traveling that you're
doing you're like living your best life
right now yeah yeah yeah how are you
enjoying just taking it all in being in
love seeing the world it's wonderful to
share the world and the sights and the
sounds and the travel with someone you
love is really special and it's fun it's
relaxing and it's it's exciting too
because now it's like alright where
we're gonna go next yeah and the
planning is almost as fun as getting to
go so we're looking forward to the next
trip yeah you're heading back to Vegas
for a couple things but one of them of
course being the 16th time hosting the
ACMs that's got to be a record
is there I can't think of any other host
it's hosted something as much as that I
don't think so I think I do set the
record with that it's fun it's exciting
once you host a show then you sit out in
the audience it's kind of wonder what
they're doing back there it's more
exciting to be hosting I think every
time you're sitting watching an award
show your thing yourself okay um yeah
you know they could use me up there I'm
just sitting here go ahead usually is
there's a lot of hard work to Austin or
so because sometimes you know I'll hear
people say oh it took us months of
preparation other times people say it's
easy they take to it right away for you
what's the process like you get your
clothes ready mm-hmm
I need six or seven we work on the
script we can't do that really until we
who's nominated who's gonna be on the
show who's gonna be there and then we
just start writing and get the most
interesting things no nothing political
we want to keep it country we want to
keep it about the music and the artists
the people in the business the fans and
we want to have fun we want to touch
people's hearts we want to make it
something that is a feel-good or at
least just feel something top on the
show yeah someone else who's going to be
doing a lot of hosting in the future as
Kelly Kelly Clarkson I was as she asked
you to come onto the show yet Kelly and
I go back a long long time ago we've
toured together we've recorded together
and so we have been talking yes mm-hmm
mm-hmm I think it's something that a lot
of people would love to see you oh I'd
love to see you hang out with Kelly
Clarkson you're gonna have a good time
she is one of the best yes absolutely
absolutely
mm-hmm she's biggest hearted and but
what you see is what you get very honest
and everybody knows that that's why
she's so loathed you know you have had
your hand in so many different aspects
of show business it's really phenomenal
as a big time fan of Reba I can't you
know help myself but ask when we're
gonna see you return to regular
television again I would love that thank
you for that mm-hmm television was
really good to me and I loved it the
difference between doing Broadway and
television is Broadway you do the same
script the same words every night eight
shows a week and with television you
have a different script every week and
you get to play in experiment and do
things a little different and it's just
always a work in progress which is a lot
of fun I love it and I'd love to get
back into it what is a challenge you
haven't had a chance to talk yet that
you're you know you're still itching to
do an authentic western movie yeah I'd
love to do that write it produce it all
of it no no come knock on my trailer and
say you're ready to get up here and do
your thing you're just putting out the
universe like telling anybody della hear
somebody make this movie so I can be in
it
ah fantastic thank you so much oh thank
you it's a pleasure good visit with you
you